they say inflation's 6.2 percent they've
been saying that it's transitory we now
have the retirement of the word
transitory like literally they should
have held an award ceremony put it in
the hall of fame it's retired yeah what
do you think about them not wanting to
use the word transitory anymore does
that mean that it's permanent or does
that mean that they just don't want to
talk about it anymore well i think
they're tired of trying to obfuscate as
to what they meant i mean i think
initially
when they said transitory they meant
transitory but then when it turned out
not to be transitory they had to kind of
redefine the word
and kind of you know to try to save face
uh but at this point they've they've
twisted it into such a pretzel that i
think they just want to walk away from
it because they really looked ridiculous
in the face of overwhelming evidence
that inflation was not transitory uh to
try to claim that it was
but i still think the methodology that
we're using today to calculate inflation
is deeply flawed and when they contrast
what's happening today to the 1970s
they never talk about the fact that the
cpi that exists today
is nothing like the one that existed
back in the night and this is cost of
living versus cost of uh goods yes i
mean and basically now it's the cost of
surviving i mean by by today's
methodology look it doesn't matter if
you're eating philly mignon or dog food
as long as you're eating uh then you got
nothing to complain about right they
don't really look at the quality even
though they claim to uh when they have
substitution or hedonics but that's a
savage car the whole thing is rigged now
but if if we were measuring prices today
and we just used the same cpi that they
used back then
i think the inflation in 2021 was as bad
if not worse than any single year of the
1970s
and so what percentage would that be i
don't know probably 13 14
probably fifteen but over ten yeah i
mean if you look at import export prices
those numbers are more real and that's
about what you see because they're
they're actually taking a look at how
much are the goods that we're importing
costing what are the goods that we're
exporting it's just apples to apples and
you can actually see the prices although
anecdotally
most of the price increases that people
you know point out to me i get a lot of
emails and people show me hey this is
what i just bought and hear the exact
same thing i bought last year or six
months ago and you look at the price
increases uh they're much bigger than
six percent okay
second thing is that we now have jerome
powell as the fed reserve chairman going
to be renominated and continue good
decision bad decision or would you have
done something different if you were
president chef
well there probably would be no fed if i
was
i would have already gotten rid of it
but um
look i predicted
on my podcast that biden would take the
coward's way out and re-nominate a pal i
mean why is it howard's way out well you
know you don't want to go out on the
limb and put somebody else in there
who's your person because then if
anything goes wrong it's your fault
right
you just leave the guy there that's
there because hey everybody wants them
there um and then if every something
goes wrong hey it's not my fault look
he's not my guy trump appointed him and
you know the republicans wanted me to
keep them and
uh so it's it's easier for him than
going out on a limb because if
if the economy does well or powell does
a good job then he gets credit for
reappointing him uh but to go out in
left field and and go for a brainerd or
somebody else and then something goes
wrong
you know what why i mean trump kind of
had to get rid of yellen because he
spent his whole campaign bashing yellen
uh basically for doing exactly what he
then bashed powell for not doing until
powell got his mind right and started
doing exactly what trump criticized
yellen for doing
um
but look he's done a lousy job i mean if
you want to look at the fed's uh
you know
mandate of price stability we clearly
don't have it
um
but you know
i i think really what the fed's job is
as far as biden is concerned is helping
me get reelected and kicking the can
down the road until the next election do
you think anyone would do something
different like what would you have done
if you were in that seat
well you know what i would do
you know i would
let the markets know that the fed is no
longer going to be setting interest
rates that the market was going to do
that and we were going to start
liquidating our holdings of u.s treasury
because they should
and of course
in so doing there would be massive
losses uh that and you know
the bill goes to the u.s taxpayer you
know as the fed unwinds its balance
sheet any losses are i o u's to the u.s
taxpayer because the u.s government has
to make the fed whole
um for that
um i also you know i would let the
government know that the fed is no
longer in the business of monetizing
government debt
and that if you want your bill back
better you better figure out how you're
going to pay for it how okay this is
what i want to talk about as well is uh
they say it's cost zero dollars is that
[ __ ] of course is [ __ ] i mean
they always say that because their
assumptions are ludicrous like break it
down for me well the revenue assumptions
they're not going to get the revenue a
lot of the revenue is supposedly going
to come from extra irs agents you know
getting the rich to pay their fair share
well you know they're not going to get
much more money out of the rich uh
there's not that many rich people other
than you crypto guys um but and you
don't pay taxes anyways you never sell
you're so salty you're so salty you guys
never sell so they're not getting
anything you'd be one of the richest
people in the world if you bought
bitcoin you first heard about it keep
going but um but they're not going to
get the revenue i mean they're obviously
mainly going to target the middle class
that's where the extra irs enforcement
is going but it's hard to get blood from
a stone so i don't think they're going
to get a lot of revenue meanwhile
all these new programs are going to cost
so much more than they think i mean
first of all they act as if the programs
are going to go away in you know five
years
because they don't want to count the
spending in the out years although we
all know that these programs never go
away once they're there they're there
forever i mean we're still dealing with
temporary programs from the second world
war you know the war ended well why are
these temporary programs still in effect
right they never go away there's an old
saying it was milton friedman there's
nothing as permanent as a temporary
government program so to pretend that
these programs are going to sunset
is nonsense but also they have grossly
underestimated the cost
because the government doesn't
understand moral hazard they don't
understand what happens so
part of the buildback better
is everybody gets free
preschool
well
the cost of preschool is going to go way
up once the government makes it free
because now the demand for preschool
goes way up and now the spree schools
start jacking up their tuition because
they know the defense industry the
defensive says oh you're gonna pay us
all this money we're gonna keep
increasing the cost of it to you because
we got a ton of money it's just like
look what government did to college
tuition before the government started
subsidizing college tuition and
guaranteeing loans college tuition was
cheap
government gets involved and it costs a
fortune so
it's gonna it's they're gonna end up
spending a lot more
on preschool than they think but i think
the biggest one is going to be if it
stays in there because the senate might
get rid of it but that is the paid
family
medical leave
because everyone's going to take that
they just assume that well only the
people that actually have a medical
emergency are going to ask for their
four-week paid vacation
no i mean didn't they learn their lesson
from the ppp or the extended
unemployment benefits if you tell an
american that they can have a four-week
paid vacation at 90 percent of salary
every single year and all they have to
do is claim they have to take care of a
sick friend or family member you don't
think they're going to say that brother
just got sick damn
everybody